maj on est parenthèse étant faire en
thèse est en fait dire monsieur le
président il ya déjà dix ans voire débat
d'hier soir où se cultivent plus
qu'utile ce que nous avons des lacunes
notamment des matines longuement du
titre car axel des rectangles et regret
réforme des retraites le bilan de la
soirée vient d'annoncer que non
seulement nous savons désormais qu'il y
aura à gimont stands régionaux
generacion de générac de lâcheté qui
lâche des grilles des vaches à lait la
crème chacune d'entre elles le conseil
d'état on savait la noaa
régis un régime différent compter les
nombreuses dérogations aux dérogations
et puis surtout et que les amateurs il
ya 23 heures hier sur le rapporteur le
rapport sur soi et ont placé en aveux
passés aux avons dix ans à cette
émission à c est le système le système
n'était jeu sans rien été je suis
parfaitement à paris n'est évidemment
univers c'est bref bref nous voyons bien
voyons bien on retourne de 22 ans
retourne devant même système votre est
prête aux retraités dont les personnes
qui n'en est pas un juste une vaste
visionnage des mesures pour aller au
sein de travail y avoir un niveau avoir
su un hiver ensuite il va baisser
profite de la présentation de la
notation de cet amendement sur le drame
porté aussi pourquoi aussi d'une petite
réagissant de la conférence les
financements d'envié en semant nos
réseaux taxi à dos reis brodeau s'y
adonner à de nombreuses nombreuses
ordonné la conférence et la conférence
n'a rien à voir on n'a rien à voir le
projet le poids conférence de films
conférences de france comme on les a
discuté de trois ou six médailles avec
2000 i have started ont instauré à ce
sujet de ce soit roger je doute une
manière d'occuper hier d'occuper parler
d'autre chose que de deux siècles de
nicolas pivot et que l'âge pilage
d'équilibrage des gaules manière
d'appeler la manière d'appeler la même
veine provisoire même promouvoir mais
n'a jamais de ce projet de loi jamais
mangé de loi jean delebarre niveau de
l'argent aux chevaux à 72 milliard et
deux milliards d'économies monde
effectivement en versements aux
partenaires vient 12 milliards
d'économies art déco milliard d arrêter
à un moment donné si haut et je veux le
dire que pour moi la démocratie c'est le
parlement et le parlement c'est le débat
et vous imposer le monologue et le
monologue c'est simplement l'antichambre
des dictatures
merci
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre au revoir
les amendements 57 73 58 88
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos votants 178 exprimé
160 majorité 80 pour 30 contre 130
les amendements sont rejetés à la suite
du rejet de l'amendement 37 donc
l'amendement 28 209 deux cent quarante
neuf tombes et les amendements 3039 1943
39 1958 tombe également bassi de quoi
s'agit-il monsieur le président
chassaigne précédemment rejetée est une
pratique traditionnelle éprouvé
séculaire qui repose sur la logique de
la discussion
elle est d'ailleurs elle est d'ailleurs
destinée à garantir la cohérence des
votes de notre assemblée
justement pour contribuer à
l'intelligibilité de la loi dans le
respect des exigences de clarté et de
sincérité du débat parlementaire
pour autant est d'ailleurs en raison des
circonstances particulières de notre
débat j'ai eu l'occasion en conférence
des présidents
sans que d'ailleurs second cela ne
soulève d'observations particulières
d'indiquer que cette règle logique sera
appliquée de manière systématique hier
systématiser le président mélenchon
s'exprimer monsieur jumelles c'est le
président mélenchon s'exprimer laissez
le président mélenchon s'exprimer c'est
l'article 58 1 mise en cause personnelle
je ne comprends pas qu'une intervention
qui porte sur un amendement soit
exclusivement consacrée à montrer du
doigt et à me traiter d'apprenti
dictateur si vous en êtes là au bout de
trois jours qu'est ce que ça va être au
bout de trois semaines puis d'abord
c'est méconnaître mes talents dans le
domaine
mais ce n'est pas acceptable président
président nous souhaiterions également
cas pour la suite des débats si vous
vouliez bien faire afficher la durée des
interventions pour que nous puissions
maîtriser totalement
le temps que nous consacrons à nos
arguments cette fois-ci et s'y trouve il
ya un instant ne s'y trouvait pas nous
souhaitons que le débat se déroule dans
de bonnes conditions quant à moi je suis
intervenu sur le fond et je
recommencerai autant de fois que le
règlement me le permet et vociférations
note aucune chance de matinée ni
aujourd'hui ni jamais merci monsieur le
président mélenchon amendement numéro 19
monsieur brun le président rappelle sur
le fondement de l'article sens s'il vous
plaît j'entends la règle que vous avez
décidé d'instaurer moi je dois dire que
vous ne pouvez pas être le seul
interprète de la jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel et qu'à tout le
moins il faudrait une conférence des
présidents pour s'entendre sur
l'interprétation de cette jurisprudence
qui en tout cas j'en suis le témoin
laisse à tout le moins des
interprétations divergentes
alors je vous demande monsieur le
président pour le bon déroulement de
cette séance une conférence des
présidents avec l'expérience de nos
administrateurs pour que nous puissions
savoir où nous allons mais on peut pas
continuer comme ça et finalement se
retrouver dans une situation qui
insécurise ray tout le monde et qu'ils
ne permettraient pas un débat de qualité
monsieur vallot monsieur vélo sur vélo
il ne s'agit pas d'interpréter il s'agit
de mettre en oeuvre une règle constante
je l'aï indiqué hier à la conférence des
présidents ça n'a pas suscité
d'opposition
je nous revois pourquoi je referai une
conférence des présidents parce que les
humeurs changerait
alors allez-y monsieur gilles c'est
inexact le feuilleton sur quel fondement
monsieur jumelles l'article 98 1 de
notre oeil décès parler monsieur jumeaux
l'article 98 1 de notre règlement ce qui
se passe est grave on a un président
d'assemblée qui nous applique un droit
coutumier
le président annonce vouloir empêcher la
discussion d'amendements alors qu'ils
sont placés dans des endroits différents
du texte si j'avais pas là j'aime et qui
n'ont pas la même portée normative et si
nous avions voulu rédiger un amendement
identique s'appliquant à l'ensemble du
texte nous l'aurions rédigé ainsi pour
justifier cela vous appliquez soi-disant
sur des références coutumière âpre
apportez-nous la preuve d'une pratique
dans cette assemblée où nous rions où
nous aurions pratiqué de la sorte
apportez-nous la preuve d'une
instruction du bureau qui vous permet de
justifier une telle décision en fait
vous êtes en train de faire en sorte de
trouver une nouvelle arme pour museler
le parlement vous êtes en train
d'inventer à la faveur de cela une
nouvelle arme pour museler votre
position non content de mettre en place
la procédure accélérée nous content
d'avoir recours à 29 ordonnance nous
content de vous asseoir sur la majorité
de l'opinion publique vous voulez
désormais empêcher l'opposition de
discuter du texte d'amender le texte
c'est purement et simplement
inacceptable monsieur le président vous
devez réunir la conférence de bureau
parce que si vous pratiquez de 1,6 vous
nous renforcer dans notre capacité à
démontrer l'inconstitutionnalité de
votre texte les arguments sont se
multiplient chaque jour un peu plus
l'avis du conseil d'état
les pratiques dans lesquelles vous nous
avez fourni l écu l'étude d'impact la
manière dont tout cela est tronquée est
désormais la manière dont les débats se
déroulent
c'est grave ce qui se passe vous n'avez
aucun élément probant père je le dis aux
groupes d'opposition
si vous laissez faire ça
vos amendements vos amendements les
amendements des groupes qui ont ils
vocation un débat du fonds sont tombés
j'appelle l'amendement numéro 19
monsieur brun madame antoine la parole
cinq minutes
la séance est reprise à la vente on vous
avait cette fois la parole
madame à la parole j'ai appelé
l'amendement va davantage la parole
bonhivers et bien il ne sera pas
examinée la parole est à l'amendement 19
pavel hapal molosses monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés je défends cet amendement de mon
collègue fabrice brin l'harmonisation
des modes de calcul des retraites entre
le secteur public et le secteur privé
est une attente forte d'une majorité des
français sur un principe d'équité
incontestable à cotisation égale
retraite égale cette question
d'harmonisation des modes de calcul des
retraites entre public et privé est plus
que jamais essentiel et son traitement
ne peut être plus longuement différées
aussi convient d'affirmer le principe
dans le titre de l'article 1a cotisation
égale retraite égale merci je le fur
merci monsieur le président il s'agit du
même amendement ça veut dire que la base
de calcul est la même que le taux est le
même que l'ensemble des dispositifs sur
les mêmes et je voudrais que le ministre
nous explique que c'est effectivement le
cas dans l'ensemble des professions
l'ensemble des systèmes
si ce n'est pas le cas à vrai dire
l'universalité dont vous vous prévalez
n'est pas pertinente
monsieur mac et oui merci monsieur le
président bah c'est un amendement comme
mes deux collègues viennent de le
défendre qu'il vous permet de réaffirmer
le principe dans le titre de l'article à
cotisation égale retraite égale donc un
abonnement visant l'harmonisation des
modes de calcul des retraites entre le
secteur public et le secteur privé
j'ai des sous-amendements madame t-il
madame t-il madame si il veut tout
comment il est défendu bon monsieur le
furan sous-amendement
monsieur le furent un sous-amendement il
est défendu cinq minutes
puis
la science ils reprise monsieur le
rapporteur sur le rapporteur sur les
amendements défavorable sur le ministre
dit favorable je mets donc pouvoir les
amendements 368 est identique qui est
pour
qu'est-ce qui a qu'est-ce qui est encore
[Musique]
question madame au tac à les médecins
motors
normalement nous avons droit de discuter
sur les amendements c'est pourquoi nous
le devions la main c'est un résulat rey
qui a été adoptée hier absolument nous
demandons une conférence des présidents
par ce que nous constatons que la règle
je suis ne porte pas sur les bosses des
amendements aux hommes nous estimons
j'ai droit à deux minutes de parole et
je remarque le chronomètre n'est pas en
fonction et que le jeune homme est mis
en place son jeu supporte le silence
pour que je puisse m'exprimer sur ce que
j'ai à dire monsieur le président et le
chrono et le chrono bien je rappelle que
la règle en vigueur a été rappelé hier
en conférence des présidents
cela figure au procès-verbal cela n'a
fait l'objet d'aucune remarque je l' ai
rappelé hier trois fois à l'issue
permettez je l' ai rappelé hier trois
fois à l'issue de votre différend sur
les amendements
par conséquent cette règle s'applique
ici dans je n'ai pas terminé je n'aurais
unis richard la conférence des
présidents
monsieur chasse m je termine juste de
dire la règle puisque j'ai le micro la
règle a changé que tous les collègues
comprennent leurs proches en jeu ce dont
il s'agit permettez moi d'expliquer
jusqu'ici s'il y avait un même
amendement x 10 7 par exemple dans notre
groupe
un seul était défendue sauf que là vous
avez introduit nuance c'est que si un
même amendement se retrouve à différents
endroits du texte le député strauss
hauer swing et recel
3 sur la question des ordonnances et
décrets vous les fait tous tomber ça
peut être des centaines de nos
amendements vont tomber avec une raie
qui a changé en cours de route monsieur
le président la vérification du quorum
la vérification du quorum parfait
je suis saisi par le président du groupe
gdr d'une demande faite en application
de l'article 61 du règlement tendant à
vérifier le quorum
avant de procéder aux votes sur les
amendements 368 est identique
je vérifie que la majorité des députés
du groupe demandeur est effectivement
présentes dans l'hémicycle ce qui est le
cas je constate que le quorum à savoir
la présence de la majorité absolue du
nombre de députés n'est pas atteint
conformément à l'article 61 du règlement
le vote aura lieu dans quinze minutes
la séance est donc suspendu pour 15
minutes
ouah
là c'est en six reprises
allez-y
vous avez la parole monsieur j'attendais
que vous me la donnez monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président ce
faire un rappel au règlement sur
l'article 100 sur le bon disons sur le
bon déroulement de la séance et sur la
règle que vous venez d expliquer moi il
ya quelque chose qui me qui me choque le
fait de dire qu'un amendement à partir
du moment il est identique dans sa
rédaction
mais qu'il se pose là différents
endroits du texte dès qu'il est tombé
une fois tous les autres tomberait on
arrive à quelque chose de totalement
ridicule je prendre à témoin mais mes
collègues non mais écoutez mes mais
monsieur sommes là parce que si vous
voulez prendre la parole chers collègues
vous vous l'avez prenait le micro si
vous avez quelque chose à dire non non
de grâce qu'il donne la parole merci
donc je vais vous prendre deux exemples
concrets et très rapide monsieur le
président j'ai pris des amendements d'un
de nos d'un autre d'un de nos collègues
qui demande à ce que lorsqu'il a indiqué
qu'il est fait référence à un décret que
ce soit pas un décret simple d'un décret
en conseil d'état
je prends par exemple l'amendement 257
qui porte sur l'article 1 sur les
indicateurs de suivi où là il est
précisé qu ils sont pris par décret et
donc l'amendement déposé qu'il soit pris
par décret en conseil d'état
je prends un autre exemple sur la
l'article 9 cette fois ci sur la valeur
du point où il a indiqué qu'il est pris
par décret et l'amendement propose qu'il
soit pris par décret en conseil d'état
on voit bien que ce sont deux sujets qui
n'ont strictement rien à voir donc ces
amendements ne peuvent pas être
considérés à l'identique pourtant le
libellé le même donc on ne peut pas être
dans cette interprétation sur le
président parce que là ça dénature
totalement notre débat donc la règle qui
consiste à dire à partir du moment où la
rédaction identique tous les amendements
tome dire s'ils sont situés à des
endroits différents dans le texte leurs
conséquences et obligatoirement
totalement différente sur le président
jacob
vous avez
monsieur monsieur jacques heures vous
avez parfaitement raison et c'est bien
pour ça que la règle en question ne
s'appliquera pas de manière aussi annie
fait stupide comme vous dites qu'elle
pourrait être appliquée l'enjeu n'est
pas de faire de la sémantique l'enjeu
simplement de dire que là vous évoquez
un décret simple décret en conseil
d'état
ç'a donc une portée juridique qui est
radicalement différente pour le reste
lorsqu'un amendement a été rejeté
je les signe rires soir trois fois et en
conférence des présidents
hier matin sans que cela soulève
d'objection et que cela porte sur des
modifications sémantiques sont portée
juridique à ce moment là les amendements
temps mais dans le cas d'espèce que vous
soulevez cela ne saurait être applicable
évidemment
[Applaudissements]
à l'évidence jacob merci monsieur
monsieur le président sur un texte aussi
important que celui là juste faire une
une remarque d'un autre homme je suis
étonné qu'il soit pas suffisamment porté
politiquement c'est pas du tout une
critique à l'égard du secrétaire d'état
mais le fait que le premier ministre qui
s'est impliqué directement sur le texte
ne soit pas présent qu'aucun ministre ne
soit présent ça ça crée un problème et
qu'ensuite
non non j'ai dit à secrétaire dit mais
ça n'est pas méprisant mais simplement
sur un texte comme celui a ensuite sur
non mais je quand même faire les ihm
seule prise ensuite sur le point que
vous venez d'évoquer on ne peut pas se
référer à l'arbitraire sur sur la
manière n'y a pas d'armes ici parce que
la décision en conférence des présidents
ça dénature complètement les choses la
conférence des présidents de la majorité
majoritaire vous le savez pertinemment
et quelles que soient les positions des
présidents des groupes d autres
présidents de groupes de toute façon le
fait majoritaire s'impose mais là
simplement on détourne complètement les
débats avec cette règle d'interprétation
monsieur le président que la majorité
sont majoritaires nous avons ri quand
démocratie c'est par la pire des règles
par ailleurs par ailleurs permettez-moi
d'observer que lorsque ceux ci a été
indiqué de manière extrêmement claire en
conférence des présidents
il n'ya il n'y a pas eu ni demande
d'explication ni observation confrères
donc monsieur garraud voulait s'exprimer
eux sévère rappel au règlement j'imagine
c'est pour aller dans le sens de ce
qu'il est d'être diplômé un collègue
aller vers un rappel au règlement sur
ses rivales à base de lin le sang voilà
très bien voilà donc je voulais monsieur
le président dire à mon tour après que
boris va l'eau se soit exprimée ici dire
que nous avons besoin en effet de
clarification parce que on doit être
d'accord sur les règles du débat ici or
de quoi s'agit-il
il ya une ambiguïté monsieur le
président dans ce que vous avez dit vous
nous dites que lorsque des amendements
sont identiques
il pourrait tomber
ça n'est pas ce dont la conférence des
présidents a délibéré puisqu'elle parle
d' objets identiques et donc là il ya
une zone grise
là il ya une marge d'interprétation
parce que si on est sûr l'objet
identique alors sans le fait que cette
liberté du parlementaire qui est
d'amender était strictement encadrée par
un point du règlement validée par le
conseil constitutionnel mais simplement
par une interprétation qui aurait été
faite en conférant de président par le
président est bien le risque c'est que
nous ne puissions valablement discuter
débattre délibéré donc ce que nous
demandons nous c'est qu'on a une
conférence des présidents pour établir
strictement cet encadrement de notre
liberté a amendé
c'est aussi simple que ça et on a besoin
parce que moi je partage votre souci
monsieur le président qu'on retrouve de
la sérénité dans cet hémicycle et pour
retrouver de la sérénité
nous devons être d'accord sur les règles
de débat ici dans l'hémicycle je vous
remercie
cela arrive il si c'est un rappel au
règlement sur le même sujet je vous
rappelle que l'article 58 des proscrits
c'est sur la base de l'article 100 oui
d'accord mais si c'est sur le même sujet
je ne vous laisserai pas prospérer je
voudrais monsieur le président hier je
vous ai interrogé sur ce sujet
en séance et vous ne m'avez pas répondu
donc c'est vrai cette raison que ce
monsieur matte cet après midi nous
sommes réintervenir sûr sur cette
question sur une règle que vous indiquez
qui n'est pas écrite et nous n'avons pas
définition qui a été adapté par la
conférence des présidents et qu'elle
dérape les trois fois hier soir bien je
vous aime c'est un rappel au règlement
dilatoire qui porte sur les mêmes
dispositions
donc nous allons nous en tenir là c'est
l'article 58 du règlement qui en
disposent
c'est le président vigier non merci
monsieur le président également sur
l'organisation de débats et où
m'accorderez quand même que au nom du
groupe liberté territoire n'y sommes pas
très souvent intervenu sur cette
organisation de débats
vous avez dit hier matin en conférence
des présidents j'étais présent si seul
et même amendement qui est déclinée 23
de suite sur le martigues il tombe ça va
c'est l'application du règlement en
revanche en revanche le président ne
peut pas y avoir de l'interprétation du
droit
si c'est sur des articles différents où
je prends d'un mot parce qu'on l'a tous
à la bouche par exemple le mot
pénibilité qu'on peut retrouver sur
plusieurs articles et que par rapport à
ce mot ça transfert au fait qu'à un
moment ou un autre il pourra y avoir un
décret en conseil d'état
le fait d'en faire tomber un endroit du
tac il faut pas faire tomber les autres
ou alors si un truc qui marche plus donc
je pense ça serait bien monsieur le
président vous précisiez les choses
moi je tiens également à ce qu'on aille
au bout des choses que l'on puisse avoir
une sérénité dans les débats
et oui m'accorderez qu'on n'en a pas
rajouté pour aucun sujet depuis le début
depuis à 17h mais là c'est un moment
absolument majeur
alors écoutez c'est le président viger
ne vociférer pas je réponds présent
vigier j'ai indiqué j'ai indiqué hier en
conférence des présidents janelle à
l'extrait dans tout le texte des
amendements ayant un objet identiques
déposés sur différents articles
s'il a été rejetée à l'implication d'une
pratique constante
si le pr si le premier de ces
amendements aient rejeté les amendements
ayant le même objet sur le même sujet
tomberont ça a été dit hier en
conférence des présidents
vient alors la serre en six reprises
avant la suspension de séance
le vote sur les amendements identiques
19 246 et 308 a été reportée à
l'application de l'article 61 lina cas
du règlement
nous allons maintenant procéder au vote
qui est pour et qui est contre ces
amendements sont rejetés cinq minutes
bien on reprend
là c'est en six reprises je vais donc
mettre au vote sur les amendements 24
809 et 42 0 70 qui ont fait l'objet d'un
avis défavorable du gouvernement et du
rapporteur qui est pour et qui est
contre
ils ne sont pas adoptées monsieur merci
monsieur président donc un rappel au
règlement sur la base de l'article 100
pour poser deux questions d'abord vous
avez indiqué qu'il s'agissait d'une
mesure concernant les amendements à un
dispositif identique
vous en avez donné une définition je
voudrais savoir si cette définition est
écrite quelque part et où est la
deuxième chose je voudrais connaître
nous voudrions connaître la liste des
amendements qui vont être concernés par
cette disposition que vous voulez
prendre tout cela ne sera fourni le
président a bad
merci monsieur le président au nom de
l'article sans également du règlement on
a un sujet on le voit d'interprétation
sur un amendement qu'elle même
dispositif était mis dans deux endroits
différents du texte et donc il peut ne
pas avoir le même sens comme l'a
démontré tout à l'heure christian jacob
et donc ma question est simple vous avez
cité tout à l'heure l'article et le
règlement et vous avez dit des pratiques
constante une pratique constante c'est
une pratique ancienne
une pratique répétée est une pratique
non interrompue donc est-ce que ici vous
pouvez nous donner un exemple de cette
jurisprudence constante de cette
pratique répétée anciennes et non
interrompue et si vous n'êtes pas en
capacité de donner cette jurisprudence
alors nous demandons au nom du groupe
est républicain une réunion de la
conférence des présidents pour clarifier
ce point qui est un point central pour
la suite nos débats et l'avenir nos
travaux il sera répondu à votre demande
et d'un moteur pour l'amendement 23 19 à
23 35 messieurs le prix
un matin les attendait à la montée à la
parole personne ne veut faire une
non mais sentez vous à l'aise disposer
librement de leur résidence mais je suis
clairement l'étude de mon amour le conte
à partir voilà non je vous prends la
parole sur mon amendement mais le
président chapelle faire un appel aux
règlements bon on va pas les exposer
votre amendement je donnerais en temps
et en heure la parole au président
chassaigne vous avez la parole si vous
le souhaitez sinon oui je prends mon
temps de parole monsieur le président le
dit en effet on essaie on essaie de
gérer mandement 23-19 je vous le
rappelle je pense que quand nous avons
un temps de parole nous pouvons nous
exprimer comme nous le voulons laurent
loquet rôle directement lié au fait vous
souvenez un moment en l'occurrence il se
trouve que nous avons un problème
d'organisation de séance parce que nous
n'avons toujours pas compris
quelles étaient les raisons qui vous
amener à changer les règles du jeu en
cours de route
et quelles étaient les centaines voire
les milliers d'amendements qu'ils
risquaient de tomber dans l'examen de ce
projet de loi et il y a cinq présidents
de groupe sur sept qui vous ont demandé
une conférence des présidents monsieur
le président je pense que d'un point de
vue démocratique
cette demande qui correspond à aucun
changement aux règles
habillée dans l'exposé de l'amendement
on essaye de trouver le garder
un débat qui serait bien si madame sur
cet amendement monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président moi je
voudrais je voudrais m'adresser à chacun
d'entre vous depuis cet après-midi ya
des nombreux public dans les tribunes
nombreux public jeune
quelle image donnons nous de nos travaux
c'est de l'anti parlementarisme de base
moi je veux remercier les jeunes de leur
présence
et je veux donner les lettres de
noblesse à nos travaux donc d abord ce
ministre oui monsieur le président
souvent là dams et messieurs les députés
sur c'est sur ces débats où nous le
passons du temps sur les titres au lieu
de travailler sur le fond j'ai un avis
défavorable ce président merci je suis
saisi par le groupe la france insoumise
d'une demande de scrutin public sur les
amendements
je vous signale que pour ce qui concerne
le groupe gdr le nombre de suspensions
de séance a été atteinte
il s'agit de deux par séance
[Musique]
je vais tenter le ce cru le scrutin est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale
rosell ne vous époumoner pas ne vous
épouser je vous ai juste indiqué que les
demandes de suspension de droit et est
atteinte
donc maintenant je soumets à l'assemblée
le voeu de monsieur roussel qui en
suspension de séance qui et pour qui et
pour
je ne veux pas vous fâcher mais vous
n'avez pas la délégation pour le
demander monsieur rousset
eh bien il est je suis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur une
hypothétique demande aux suspensions de
séance par monsieur jumelles qui a
délégué du groupe gdr le la demande de
scrutin donc est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale et
nous allons attendre quelques minutes
autant que vous voulez
oh
bien mes chers collègues nous allons
procéder au scrutin sur la demande
présentée par le groupe gdr d'une
suspension de séance je vous prie de
bien vouloir gagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats du scrutin en votant
214 exprimé 212 majorité 107 pour 65
contre 147 il n'y aura donc pas de
suspension de séance
monsieur jumelles pour présenter le
sous-amendement 42,050 sur lequel j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public que je fais annoncé dans
l'hémicycle dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale ces jumelles
bientôt les monsieurs et en y en a
plusieurs
monsieur k tenace
monsieur le président je vais faire un
rappel au règlement en titre de
l'article 58 alinéa 5 de notre règlement
et je le fais parce que jusqu'à preuve
du contraire président vous êtes le
président de l'assemblée nationale vous
n'êtes pas le secrétaire général du
groupe la retraite en moins vous êtes là
pour garantir vous êtes là pour garantir
la qualité de nos débats et je soutiens
président devait fonder votre demande
je vais la faune des tribunaux mesures
non vous avez évoqué l'article 58 alinéa
2 qui ne correspond en rien ce que vous
évoquez vos mort est mal vous m'aurez
malentendu président j'ai évoqué
l'article 58 alinéa 5 puisque je vais
procéder à une demande de suspension de
séance
car effectivement vous avez changé les
règles en cours de jeu président il faut
que ça se sera fait minutes la séance
est suspendue
oui monsieur roussel
merci monsieur le président au nom de
l'article sont je souhaite faire un
rappel au règlement car vous remettez en
cause notre droit constitutionnel à
l'amendement
vous avez cité un soi-disant pv qui fixe
une règle qui est ici contesté ce pv
n'étaient accessibles par personne il
n'existe nulle part
nous demandons une conférence des
présidents et si vous ne donnez pas de
conférence des présidents je redemande
suspension de séance et je redemande un
scrutin public sur la suspension de
séance jusqu'à ce que nous obtenions la
conférence des présidents n'avait pas
vous n'avez pas mandat pour demandé un
scrutin public 71 rue il faut écouter
quand je vous dis les choses mais
inquiétez pas vous inquiétez pas on va
ça on va s'arranger
il va y avoir le scrutin public
indication sur le scrutin public
bien y at il ou pas sur le président oui
auparavant je voudrais attendait au nom
au nom d'un rappel règlement au nom de
l'article je reviendrai près de 66 ans
que c'est important ce que je vais vous
dire ce que je pense ça peut peut-être
qu internet d'arranger les choses à
partir de je m'appuie sur l'article 5
alinéa 5
le président a bag tout à l'heure a
demandé que vous fassiez la
démonstration que de façon constante que
de façon constante ce que vous appliquez
aujourd'hui ça a été le cas or moi j'ai
ici la preuve j'ai ici la preuve que ça
n'a pas été appliquée de façon constante
je vais prendre je vais prendre trois
exemples d'un anglais c'était sur la
garantir l'avenir et la jussie système
de retraites en 2013
j'ai ici entre les mains oui j'ai
enchaîné les faits ont montré qu'il n'y
a pas la constance par rapport à ça de
l'interprétation
mais elle attend des gmg exact je puis
vous assurer que la règle qui est en
vigueur a été moult fois appliquée et ce
n'est pas parce qu'elle n'a pas été tout
le temps appliquer qu elle n'est pas
applicable
donc ça ne c'est pas parce que vous
trouveriez une exception que cela
deviendrait une règle c'est cela que je
souhaite vous expliquer et que nous
allons donc appliqué sur la base de ce
fondement
quant à ce rappel au règlement il est
superfétatoire avec une demande scrutin
public c'est bien ça publiques parfp et
donc nous allons annoncer le scrutin
public sur la demande du présent chasse
n y qui aura lieu dont blanc 5 minutes
bien mes chers collègues
nous allons donc voter sur la demande de
suspension de séance qui a été réclamé
par monsieur le président chassaigne
nous allons donc procéder au scrutin le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 200
exprimé 200 majorité simple pour 59
contre 141 donc la demande de suspension
de séance est rejetée sur chenille cause
la parole oui merci monsieur le
président je souhaite au nom du groupe
socialiste et apparenté au titre de
l'article sans alinéa 5 faire un rappel
au règlement toute limitation de la
liberté d'amendement des parlementaires
doit résulter d'une disposition
explicite du règlement de l'assemblée
nationale est validée par le conseil
constitutionnel
lorsque votre majorité a voulu limiter
la liberté présenter des amendements
identiques à la réformer l'article son
alinéa 5 du règlement
celui-ci n'évoque que des amendements
identiques et pas des amendements ayant
un objet identique
or toute limitation d'une liberté
d'amendement est d'interprétation
stricte
donc nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure la
jurisprudence qui évoque une pratique
constante répétées et ancien votre texte
dispose déjà de 29 ordonnance de son
décret qui dès ses 6 le parlement je
pense pas que vous allez rajouter le
rejet sans discussion de nombreux
amendements sont qu'on sache combien
d'amendements sont concernés et quels
sont ces amendements concernés merci
messieurs janicot j'ai indiqué en
réponse à une question de monsieur
dharréville qui était identique à la
vôtre que je lui ferais donnerez
connaissance dans les minutes qui
viennent dans les minutes qui viennent
des amendements concerné mais rassurez
vous il y aura suffisamment de sujets de
débat donc monsieur suspension de séance
pour cinq minutes
d'accord monsieur jumelles
sur l'amendement 42,050 le
sous-amendement pardon noter un prélat
monsieur le président que j'ai retiré au
nom du groupe la demande de scrutin
public sur cet amendement et donc pour
tout ça pour vous être agréable
ceci étant dit voilà trois heures et
c'est évidemment profondément lié à
l'amendement que je veux défendre que
nous avons à faire un président de
l'assemblée nationale qui normalement
doit être à l'écouté de la pluralité de
cet hémicycle qui nous explique que en
substitution au règlement de l'assemblée
nationale en substitution de la
jurisprudence constante du conseil
constitutionnel nous allons désormais
appliqué à cette importante réforme des
retraites un droit coutumier et donc
vous imaginez bien que nous ne pouvons
accepter une telle dérive démocratique
quoi que vous en disiez les
parlementaires de l'opposition
souhaitent débattre du fond d'ailleurs
nous n'avons aucune difficulté à cela
tellement nous sommes sûrs en discutant
du fond de vous faire toucher le fond
de vous faire toucher le fond de votre
incapacité à répondre aux question que
nous vous posons depuis dix jours en
commission spéciale et depuis que les
débats ont démarré ici
monsieur le président vous gagneriez
nous avions pris la nouvelle gouvernance
de l'assemblée nationale sous un jour
nouveau et nous pensions d'ailleurs que
à nouveau la sérénité serait au rendez
vous de cet hémicycle ça tranchait
singulièrement avec l'ancienne
gouvernance je pense qu'il est encore
temps de nous démontrer que nous avons
raison d'espérer en cela garantir les
droits de l'opposition garantir le droit
individuel à défendre des amendements
garantir la possibilité pour chaque
groupe de défendre son point de vue hier
6 me sur j'aime nature à permettre cela
bien sûr cet amendement qui vient d'être
donc défendu monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président je vais
réitérer mes propos de tout à l'heure il
ya des enseignants qui ont amené des
jeunes ici présent nous ne sommes pas à
la hauteur de 2 de ces débats donc
défavorable
défendre monsieur le président monsieur
monsieur le fur
merci monsieur le président ce rappel au
règlement pour l'article 100 sur le
fondement de l'article sans monsieur le
président nous sommes finalement
confronté au problème suivant vous
considérez que quand un débat de
principe exprimé dans un mot dans une
expression a été tranchée à l'occasion
d'un article
cette décision faut pour l'ensemble des
articles et ce débat ne peut plus être
évoqué d'autres considèrent l' inverse
tout est affaire de précédents tout est
affaire de précédents je ne prétends pas
avoir tous les précédents tête mais j'en
ai un
j'en ai un très précis il s'agissait
d'un débat tout aussi électrique
il s'agissait d'un débat qui avait
rassemblé dans cet hémicycle encore plus
de parlementaires
il s'agissait d'un débat qui crée des
oppositions considérable entre nous il
s'agissait du bar ya ce pour tous et moi
et d'autres nous avions à chaque
amendement insisté sur un principe
simple qui s'exprimait dans des mots
pères et mères parce que c'est notre
conception de la famille et que nous
considérions nous devions l'affirmé nous
avons défendu ce type d'amendements à
l'occasion de chacun des articles de
chacun des articles et j'ai parfaitement
le souvenir qu en aucun cas les
présidents de séance qui s'étaient
succédé
né d'une manière ou d'une autre censurer
ces amendements et censurer les propos à
chaque fois nous étions battus c'est la
réalité de la majorité et nous nous
inclinons mais à chaque fois nous avons
pu défendre cet amendement c'est
l'honneur des théâtres cette assemblée 2
permettre à tous chacun de défendre ses
convictions chers collègues cher que les
jo je comprends que l'émotion puisse
susciter une certaine emphase
mais et c'est très respectable mais de
quoi parlons nous l'assemblée a rejeté
plusieurs fois un amendement substituant
au système universel le mot inéquitable
portant sur l'intitulé du titre premier
ce rejet fait donc logiquement tombé 74
amendement strictement identiques
déposés au nom de chaque membre du
groupe gdr soit un total de 1100 84
amendements ayant le même dispositif est
le même exposé sommaire
voilà de quoi il s'agit il s'agit de
dire que lorsque l'assemblée nationale a
toujours foi dit un mot un épithète ne
se substituerait pas un autre eh bien ce
ne serait pas le cas dans l'ensemble des
articles donc ceci non ceux ci ceci
n'implique aucune portée normative et
est donc parfaitement fondées conforme à
la décision de la conférence des
présidents qui est souveraine et bien
entendu ne sera fait aucune application
si ce n'est celle ci cette jurisprudence
voilà tout de même de quoi on parle
monsieur vélo vous avez demandé la
parole pour un rappel au règlement appel
règlement mais c'est le président sur le
fondement de la recherche de l'article
sans dire puisque les citoyens qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui sont interpellés
ce qui est en jeu c'est une réforme qui
va concerner des millions de français
pendant des décennies et des décennies
qui représente 25% de notre dépense
publique
vous avez choisi la voie de la
démocratie expéditive qui est à peu près
aussi curieuse que la justice expéditive
en se hissant une procédure accélérée
qui n'a aucune nécessité qui n'a aucune
nécessité
je crois que c'est un honneur exigeant
que de représenter les françaises et les
français dans leur diversité
vous avez été élu pour appliquer votre
programme nous avons été élus pour le
combattre
c'est un fait c'est un fait le rappel au
règlement est le suivant et or suivant
la conférence des présidents a le
pouvoir d'organiser les débats
il n'a pas le pouvoir de réécrire le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale
c'est ce que vous avez fait avec une
disposition portant sur le même objet
dans des articles différents et nous
demandons à nouveau la conférence des
présidents pour vérifier si en effet les
présidents sont d'accord il se trouve
que cinq des sept groupes voulons
demander monsieur le président faites
vivre votre institution
défendez la à tout le moins et accepter
que soit repris s'il doit y avoir sujet
d'incompréhension que l'on puisse à
nouveau en débattre mais vous ne pouvez
pas comme ça décidé d'escamoter les
choses vous êtes en plus de ça d'entente
dans une forme de 2,2 vous vous
bâillonner le le débat regardez nous
n'avons pas déposé plus d'amendements
que votre majorité monsieur le président
est particulièrement mauvais et vous
n'avez pas répondu sur le nombre
d'amendements que cela ferait tomber
pour ce qui concerne les amendements
je viens de répondre pour le parti
communiste non pour l'ensemble des
amendements concernent les données dans
le détail on en a pas je veux j'ai dit
non attendez on achève à l'eau ne soyez
pas nouveau mais reçoit en plus vous
n'avez pas la peau c'est la conférence
des présidents n'a pas le pouvoir de
réécrire seul le règlement de
l'assemblée voilà la réalité merci
monsieur vélo ce que je vous invite
c'est d'abord et vous le savez que ce
n'est pas la présidence de l'assemblée
nationale qui choisit telle ou telle
procédure
donc ne ne portait pas des reproches
qu'ils ne sont pas imputables pour le
reste pour le reste je viens d'indiquer
ce dont il s'agit et quand vous me dites
qu'il s'agit d'un bâillon alors qu'il
restera minime à 39 mille amendements à
débattre
croyez moi croyez moi vous aurez le
temps d'exprimer tous vos arguments
simplement comme cela a été décidé de
manière souveraine par la conférence des
présidents
eh bien lorsque cette épithète
ressurgira et bien elle sera considérée
comme avoir était tombé et ilan et ainsi
décider parce qu'il en a été décidé
ainsi par la conférence des présidents
dont je dois faire respecter les
décisions sur l'amendement
monsieur jumelles dans les deux passages
itil monsieur julien de posséder
trente ans
[Musique]
monsieur jumelles
monsieur mais ça viendra
monsieur jumelles alesi président il
s'agit pour moi de répondre à la
proposition quoi s'agit-il de répondre à
la proposition que vous nous faites mais
je ne veux une proposition je vous
rappelle les règles alors s'il vend une
proposition je vais tout de même pouvoir
commenter la vôtre il ne vous a pas
échappé
elle est l'objet de votre intervention
de répondre à votre conformément à
l'article
un article lartigue leçons du règlement
intérieur non non c'est le président
monsieur le président vous nous fait une
proposition qui consiste il bien compris
mais peut-être ai-je mal compris de
faire tomber un peu plus de mille
amendements déposés sur le 95 184
amendements déposés par le groupe
communiste sur des articles qui ont une
portée normative non uniquement sur un
épithète d'intituler jure des articles
qui ont une portée normative différentes
le premier article pose des principes et
les objectifs du système universel
l'article 2 couvre le champ
d'application n'est que sur la forme
l'article 12 euros- l'écart semblait a
parfaitement compris ce dont il s'agit
non
la parole est à monsieur mélenchon pour
un rappel au règlement l'article 58
proscrit ce type de rappel permanent
monsieur le président mélenchon vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président moi j'interviens aussi sur le
l'esprit autant que la lettre de
l'article 100 du règlement alinéa 5
le président de séance veille aux
exigences de clarté et de sincérité du
débat parlementaire
fumant non ça c'est pas vous qui l'avez
dit c'est le conseil constitutionnel
mais mais c'est pourquoi je vous aurais
recourir à une limitation que pour
prévenir les usages abusifs bon
oui c'est bien cela qu'il s'agit
monsieur le président monsieur le
président votre enthousiasme me fait
plaisir je vous retrouve tels que vous
étiez dans la loi sur les faits que nous
vous pensez que la vérité existe et que
c'est vous qui la dea qui en disposent
et ben non
et ben non voyez vous ça fait un ou deux
millénaires qu'on discute sur ce sujet
j'en viens l'objet de mon intervention
monsieur le président il me semble que
vous méconnaissez le fait que nous
sommes cinq présidents sur 7 à vous dire
que nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
l'interprétation que vous avez tiré de
la conférence des présidents
donc nous vous demandons non pas comme
une faveur mais comme un droit qui
résulte de notre situation particulière
de président de groupe que cette
assemblée des présidents dont vous êtes
le premier prix mousse hinte
reparaissent une terre par s parmi vos
semblables
vous ne nous dominer pas vous en êtes
d'accord j'en suis certain alors je vous
dis que moi comme président de groupe
je ne suis pas convaincu par ce que vous
m'avez dit et vous ne me permettait pas
d'organiser mon travail pourquoi parce
que vous venez à l'instinct d'abroger
mille abandonnant j'ai le droit de vous
demander combien d'autres vous comptez
en abrogée par la suite d'après
l'évaluation que vous avez fait des
contenus qui vous paraissent identiques
ce qui n'est pas notre cas
parce que moi je dois organiser la
présence constante dans cet hémicycle
d'un petit groupe de 17 personnes qui
n'a donc pas les mêmes possibilités de
rotation que vous avez vous à plus de
300 et donc comme nous avons parmi nous
mais oui mais comme nous avons parmi
nous des gens qui sont plus des
spécialistes de tel ou tel domaine maire
j à présent n'ont pas merci donc je
demande le corps minutes
oui bah là faisait de la vérification du
quorum mesure avancent normalement je
veux parler
permettez moi simplement de vous dire
que lorsqu'il y avait fait sept
présidents de groupe
en conférence des présidents ce qui est
décidé c'est que chaque président
s'exprime nantes de députés qui ont été
élus par le peuple
et si le peuple n'a souhaité qu' il n'y
a que 17 députés dans votre groupe moi
je n'y peux rien
c'est simplement la conséquence des
élections de sorte que de sorte que dans
la conférence des présidents
les choses ne se calcule pas par nombre
de présidents de groupe mais simplement
parce qu'ils représentent
ensuite je vous ai donné la réponse à la
question posée par monsieur dharréville
qui était de savoir quelle était la
conséquence de l'application des choses
j'ai indiqué que en tout et pour tout
don vous pourrez paisiblement organiser
votre temps de travail
en tout et pour tout il s'agit de 1184
amendement qui qui comprennent le même
dispositif est le même
exposé sommaire et comme vous avez eu
raison de citer le conseil
constitutionnel c'est lui même qui dans
sa décision de juillet 2019 a qualifié
ce qu'étaient les amendements qui était
de nature à prévenir un usage abusif
c'est ce qui faisait l'objet de dépôt
simultané massif comportant le même
dispositif est le même exposé sommaire
je crois donc pouvoir dire que nous
sommes d'accord allez on continue pas
suffi sur quoi demandez-vous le forum
mais attendez borgore au vote alors
alors monsieur mélange le bureau de
l'assemblée nationale dans sa réunion du
mercredi 23 février 1994 a confirmé la
règle suivant laquelle une seule demande
de vérification du quorum est recevable
au cours du même débat dans le même jour
deux séances
cette décision a été appliquée sans
exception depuis lors il n'y a donc pas
lieu de donner suite à la demande qui
vient d'être présenté
monsieur le président abbas vous avez
demandé la parole mais monsieur le
président abbas s'était inscrit avant
vous vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
écoutez franchement depuis tout à
l'heure je pense que les conditions du
débat se dégrade de manière très
importante et vous le savez nous sommes
un groupe responsable nous avons mes
chers collègues nous avons déposé moins
de 25 amendements par député chez le
groupe républicain
donc vous pouvez pas nous excuser
d'obstruction ou d'irresponsabilité
monsieur le président je vous ai posé
tout à l'heure une question claire dans
l'intérêt justement de sortir de ce
débat par le haut la question était sur
la pratique constante ou pas de la
jurisprudence que vous venez de mettre
sur la table
je renvoie simplement la réserve
d'interprétation du conseil
constutionnel et là où il ya une
difficulté c'est qu'en aucun cas le
conseil constitionnel ne parle de la
conférence des présidents
le conseil communal sis toujours le
président de séance et c'est au
président de séance d'établir la clarté
des débats est pas la conférence des
présidents
en amont de le faire et donc à partir de
là c'est contraire à ce que dit le
conseil conscio neil dans ce que nous
demandons chez les républicains
c'est de répondre à notre question de
cette pratique constante c'est à dire
répéter anciennes et non et non
discontinue de savoir si oui ou non
c'est possible comme vous n'avez pas
répondu
eh bien vous nous donnons la possibilité
de lui répondre en demandant une
suspension de séance mme
cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
la séance s'est reprise monsieur
jumelles pour le 42 51
madame décès il est défendu le 42 50 2 à
la buffet il est défendu le 42 54 fondu
et le 53 j'imagine idem sur à porter
défavorable défavorable je vais donc
mettre ensemble madame banon
merci monsieur le président oui il est
clair que le débat ont déjà commencé
depuis maintenant deux jours et l'on
voit bien que l'universalité dont il est
question ici n'en est pas une
ça vous a été dit tout à l'heure par le
président mélenchon que si on
considérait que les choses devaient
universel alors elle devait s'appliquer
à tous comme le sont des droits
fondamentaux qui sont universelles et
qu'il ne pouvait pas y avoir dans torse
si vous commencez à créer des catégories
au sein de l'universalité ce n'est plus
de l'universalité
ou alors je vous retourne la réplique
s'il peut y avoir des dispositions
spécifiques au sein d'un régime
universel alors le système actuel est
déjà un régime universel donc ça n'a pas
de sens vous voyez bien vous même que ça
n'a pas de sens
il faut donc dissipé les doutes qu'il
peut y avoir sur l'université de ce
régime non ce n'est pas un régime
universel
il est très clair que ce n'en est pas un
puisque vous l'avez rappelé il y a déjà
des dispositions spécifiques
que ce soit pour les pompiers que ce
soit pour les policiers pour les
gendarmes pour la banque de france etc
etc
il ne faudrait pas que nous commencions
la discussion sur de mauvaises bases
car oui nous pensons que vous êtes
illégitime a porté ce projet car ce
n'était pas dans votre programme alors
ça ne sert à rien de dire que vous êtes
les plus nombreux que vous avez été élu
etc
il faut laisser toute la place à la
discussion au débat dans cet hémicycle
sinon ça ne sert à rien sinon expliquez
nous et vous auriez peut-être dû le
faire dès le premier jour où on s'est
réunis ici qu'on vous laisse les clés
que vous vous débrouillez entre vous et
que vous n'êtes qu'une excroissance de
l'exécutif et puis c'est tout quoi on
rentre chez nous on fait autre chose
bon or ce n'est pas le cas ici c'est
l'assemblée nationale le conte débat on
parle alors des fois ça vous plaît pas
évidemment des fois ce que vous dites ça
me plaît pas non plus mais en même temps
c'est ça qui fait qu'on peut encore dire
on prend un peu dire que c'est une
démocratie donc le caractère universel
de cette loi il est il ne l'est pas
c'est pourquoi nous demandons d'adopter
ces sous-amendements et ses amendements
pour clarifier la situation
merci monsieur au seul monsieur le
président je vais demander une
suspension de séance
kid je vais demander une suspension de
séance
je vais demander un vote et mon
président un scrutin public et je vous
annonce que je le ferai à chaque fois
jusqu'à ce que vous convoquer une
conférence des présidents et qu'il y ait
une décision prise à l'unanimité
concernant l'organisation de nos débats
et donc je demanderai une suspension de
séance à chaque fois je vous préviens
donc pour l'organisation des débats
je vous demande encore une fois comme
cinq présidents de groupes l'ont fait
ici qu'il y ait une conférence des
présidents pour organiser la tenue de
nos débats il ne vous aura pas échappé
que nous sommes entrés en résistance
ici aussi dans l'hémicycle sur le
président chassaigne je demande donc un
scrutin public sur cette demande de
suspension bien messieurs vous
m'annoncez que vous allez systématiser
ce type de demande
et bien moi je vous annonce que je ne le
ferai plus droit puisque ce faisant vous
contournez l'article 58 du règlement en
voulant finalement aller au delà du
droit qui est accordée à chacun de
pouvoir avoir de suspension de droit et
que cette manière cette manoeuvre
dilatoire fondent que je vous le refuse
monsieur d'arrivée je vais donc je vais
donc mettre voir monsieur arrive il
faisait d'abord vous avez la parole
monsieur dans les villes merci le
président puisque je voudrais réagir sur
cet amendement non sans avoir au
préalable que c'est pas parce que le
règlement a été mal réécrit règlement
qui n'ait été voté que par la majorité
coup ne vous ne devait pas l'appliquer
donc je proteste contre la décision que
vous annoncez cela étant dit la forme du
débat puisque tout à l'heure les
tribunes ont été prises à partie
notamment par le rapporteur mais sans
doute pas seulement la forme du débat et
je pense que ça des vertus pédagogiques
de l'expliquer et bien lié au fond et
que naturellement il faut respecter les
formes pour que le débat soit sincère et
pour que véritablement la démocratie
puisse s'exprimer
et donc je crois que c'est aussi ça le
débat que nous avons est que c'est un
débat important qui doit pas nous
empêcher effectivement d'aborder le fond
sur le fond vous parlez d'universalité
je vous ai interrogé hier sur le taux de
remplacement il n'y a aucune versalité
par exemple du taux de remplacement
puisque avoir des taux extrêmement
différents selon les générations selon
l'âge de départ selon etc
voilà donc je continue de contester
cette universalité et d'autre part je
vous repose la question qui vous a été
posée hier sur le coût supposé de cette
exception à l'universalité qui est fait
qui est fait pour les personnes entre 3
et 8 passes combien d'après vous cela va
coûter cette transition va-t-elle coûter
et comment allez-vous la finance et ça
fait partie des objets de la discussion
de la conférence du financement moi
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la feuille
de route que vous avez donnés à monsieur
m'arrête
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez participé
hier qui pour le gouvernement a
participé à cette réunion et qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous dire de cette
première réunion le parlement doit être
informé similienne pardon monsieur le
président il ya là pour rappeler le
règlement
merci monsieur le président rappel au
règlement au titre de l'article 50 4-6
l'orateur ne doit pas s'écarter de la
question relative à
mandement et c'est très exactement ce
que vient de faire l'orateur avec tout
le respect que je peux porter à son
propos monsieur 1000 yens merci monsieur
le président monsieur milian vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
alors mes chers collègues à ce moment
des débats qui dure depuis hier 17
heures et on répète inlassablement les
mêmes choses
je vais moi à mon tour aussi répété
quelques vérités qui sont bonnes à
entendre dans cet hémicycle et avec
lesquels la plupart des démocrates et
des républicains sont d'accord la
démocratie la démocratie c'est le
parlement le parlement c'est le débat
vous vous nous enfermez dans un
monologue et le monologue c'est
l'antichambre de la dictature
monsieur dupont-aignan
moi je voudrais monsieur le président
revenir à l'amendement et je voudrais
simplement à propos d'universalité
réitéré la question que j'ai posée dix
fois hier dans la journée sans aucune
réponse sur le coup pour le régime futur
du nouveau régime spécial sur les plus
hauts revenus
vous ne donnez toujours pas le chiffre
vous demander un débat sérieux aux
parlementaires vous reprochez aux uns et
aux autres
x obstruction ou x amendements avant de
vouloir donner des leçons de morale aux
autres
est ce que les ministres le rapporteur
pourrait donner à la représentation
nationale
l'estimation du coût annuel pendant la
période transitoire de ce nouveau régime
spécial sur les hauts revenus
on ne peut pas demander aux
parlementaires un travail sérieux si le
ministre et les rapporteurs ne donne pas
les chiffres que chacun est en droit
d'attendre
si je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 42,050 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du rapporteur et du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté
trg rappel au règlement au titre de
l'article 58
vous avez confondu sur quels fondements
sur le fondement de long sur le fond
demain de l'erreur vous venez de
commettre monsieur le président vous
avez confondu gel rien cadres et
l'alinéa 5 c'est à dire la ligne ac 4
pour trois jours après le règlement jeu
et en ce qui concerne le gymnase 5
vous n'avez pas de pouce vous ne pouvez
pas empêcher une suspension de séance
c'est à l'assemblée de le décider
les jaunards das que les anglais
décident par scrutin public
l'alinéa 5 est très clair et bien le
rapport à ça vous en faites unis fed se
tenait prête à tirer de pratique
constante dans notre assemblée
vous êtes mieux passé que d'autres pour
le mesurer vous avez plus d'ancienneté
que d'autres que lorsque des demandes de
suspension de séance fut sa devancière
cet argument vise à détourner
je dis bien détourné le droit de deux
suspensions de séance par groupe
et bien cela peut être refusée par la
présidence de la séance ce qui est mon
cas
monsieur le président mélenchon
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président maintenant la
parole moi je fais partie des gens qui
souhaitent que le thon baisse
ouah on a le droit non mais vous pouvez
ricaner vous m'impressionnez pas j'en ai
déjà vu d adam comme vous laisser
s'exprimer en mélenchon et donc on a
besoin de retrouver des marques pour
savoir comment on avance je me suis
renseigné pendant la suspension de
séance pour savoir si ce que vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur le
président ferrand était définitive c'est
à dire il y à 1000 amendements de
supprimer du point de vue de votre
appréciation 1184 jusqu'au bout du texte
bon alors 1184 mais prix définitif
application définitive de la
jurisprudence arrêté par la confiance
recommencez pas attendez je vous propose
de calmer le jeu c'est pas le moment de
remettre à zéro mais oui mais préservé
rang compris oui oui mais vous êtes en
parlementaires avisés et moi aussi
donc quand je vous pose la question sur
moi je j'assume tout donc la longue
expérience vous salir de vous déranger
mais bon 1184 amendement ça c'est pour
la raison sur laquelle vous êtes
intervenu tout à l'heure est ce que vous
vous engagez devant nous qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre occasion qui vous conduirai en
annuler encore mille autres et mille
autres et mille autres
est ce que ces mille autres une fois
mille une fois pour toutes
c'est ça ma question non non non la
règle nous la contestons il est inutile
de me répondre que c'est la règle nous
ne sommes pas d'accord il est inutile de
me dire que c'est la vraie vérité nous
ne sommes pas d'accord je vous pose une
question très précise pour organiser mon
travail et j'ai besoin
une fois que vous aurez répondu monsieur
le président que vous nous fassiez passé
la liste des 1184 amendement qui sont
dorénavant d'après votre interprétation
et celle de vos groupes i qui va être
appliqué pour être supprimés
donc nous avons besoin de savoir
qu'est-ce qui est supprimé je vous
signale ça fait une heure qu'on discute
sans savoir de quoi c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire 1184 donc
dites-nous lesquels oui mais il aurait
pu apaiser tout le monde en donnant la
liste ee en dix ans les quais les gens
qui est définitive
l'occasion vous est proposé
faire mais il n'y a aucune difficulté
simplement j'ai le sentiment que tout le
monde n'écoute pas bien tout le monde
ici en tout cas je trie moins que vous
monsieur est un donc monsieur le
président mais l'enjeu votre question
est clair la réponse que j'ai plusieurs
fois exprimé être encore plus clair
la règle qui a été adopté par la
conférence des présidents s'appliquera
exclusivement et jusqu'au bout au sens
aux 184 amendements qui ont été
indiquées sans qu'il y ait d'autres
situations sans que vous ayez cette
crainte qu'il y ait d'autres situations
similaires qui s'applique et la liste
des amendements concernés sera remise à
l'ensemble des présidents de groupes
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
en réponse à notre rapport comment elle
est en train d'être établi mais vous
avec le dépasser voilà donc voilà vous
êtes satisfait dans l'ensemble de vos de
vos questions monsieur le président que
les satisfaits du fait que vous ayez que
vous m'ayez répondu et je vois que vous
le faites sur un ton qui m'a l'air plus
amicale que les occasions précédentes
pour autant je vous fais remarquer que
vous avez parlé de 184 à mon nom mills
et la voie à wim alors voilà non 1984
alors si le seul à voir julien plusieurs
fois il 184 mais président
c'était juste une remarque pour la
clarté est bien assurée les choses 1184
vous nous dites vous inquiétez pas vous
les aurez banon c'est maintenant que je
vais vous parce que je ne peux pas
organiser le travail si je ne sais pas
si dans un article 3 amendements
je vais en avoir dit ce qu ont disparu
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me
permets respectueusement de solliciter
une interruption science pour que vous
ayez le temps de me remettre ladite
liste et tout après il ira très bien
j'en suis certain
bien les interruptions de séance de
droit ayant été déjà utilisée
nous allons attendre et nous allons
avancer et la liste vous être portées
dans les minutes qui viennent
voilà monsieur jumelles alors dites moi
de quoi il s'agit parce que je souhaite
moi ne pas obstruer le débat je bien
très agréable mais pas complices allez-y
allez-y vous voulez pas la parole mal en
point et là la question n'est pas de
savoir si on veut discuter
tranquillement ou non d'aller ou de quoi
s'agit-il de foot ou de vous laisser
revenir tranquillement sur le droit
contre le gel venait à l'essentiel face
agite le droit à suspense joie s'agit-il
de vous faire un rappel au règlement sur
quel fondement vertu de l'article 58
aliéné à 5 qui confirme que le droit à
suspension je vous ai déjà répondu sur
les mêmes l'étranger elle que ne soit
pas permis par notre règlement je vous
ai répondu ma réponse est définitif
voilà alors l'amendement 42,050 hier
dans le présent mignola à l'effet
rappelé que les interventions ne doivent
pas s'éloigner du contenu de
l'amendement vous avez la parole alors
quel moment vous voulez vous défendre
celui dont je suis signataire mais chez
le président oui d'accord dont on ne
savait pas exactement même pas tous ceux
là ont déjà été défendue si si si non
non ceux là ont été défendus
c'est à dire le 42 51 le 42 50 2 le bas
ils ont été défendues par la voix de
madame buffet donc je vais je devais
donc passer au vote sur ces amendements
sur ses amants et je vous donnerai la
parole pour les amendements suivant
monsieur hutin vous la parole
comment est ce que tu dis là monsieur
hutin vous avez la parole pme je vais je
viens de me faire injurier publiquement
jour et savoir ce qu'il ya des vies pour
monsieur hutin
s'il vous plaît vous avez la parole
allez monsieur hutin vous avez la parole
monsieur nogal laisser monsieur est un
poursuivre bien monsieur hutin voulait
la parole ou pas vous avez la parole
simon monsieur président simon troisième
mandat c'est la première fois que
j'entends ça
vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
laisser monsieur hutin s'exprimer je
vais me permettre de défendre
l'amendement en vous disant clairement
monsieur le président tout ça ne veut
pas continuer de cette même manière
c'est un possible impossible quand il ya
un nombre de décisions gouvernementales
qui ne dit que dont cette assemblée ne
sera pas on ne décidera pas ici de ce
qui va se passer sur la réforme de
retraites on ne parle pas de 1000
personnes on ne parle pas de 500
personnes on n'en parle pas de dix mille
personnes
on parle de 60 millions d'individus or
aujourd'hui le financement n'est pas
acquis que les choses soient très
claires personne ne dit que tout ça est
évident et aujourd'hui vous avez décidé
monsieur le président que votre
présidence dont parlait le rapporteur
tout à l'heure quand les gens viennent
visiter les jeunes dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure vous êtes au même niveau
que tous les autres députés monsieur le
président et je suis désolé vous n'avez
pas le droit de décider seuls de ce qui
va se passer durant ces quinze jours
c'est impossible il ya une opposition
qui aux minoritaires
nous sommes des gens qui défendent on a
une majorité de gens dans cette
population et j'espère que cela pourra
continuer comme ça et franchement par
rapport s'il se passe encore tout à
l'heure et encore maintenant les groupes
d'opposition sont méprisent et méprisent
et caen sont cinq présidents de groupes
demandent une réunion
je n'ai jamais vu jamais vu un président
qui ait refusé de réunir la conférence
des présidents
merci monsieur par alex merci monsieur
présidence et si pour un rappel au
règlement sur la base de l'article 100
un peu de calme s'il vous plaît monsieur
marc l'ex à la parole le président pour
vous dire que notre surprise sur
l'interprétation que vous faites du
règlement de l'assemblée nationale et
surtout à la lecture qui a été rappelé
par plusieurs collègues d'autres groupes
des réserves d'interprétation faite par
le conseil constitutionnel le 4 juillet
2019 sur la modification du règlement de
l'assemblée nationale
certes le règlement de l'assemblée
nationale prévoit une limitation du
droit d'amendement lorsque il apparaît
que c'est une obstruction aux débats aux
débats parlementaires et concessionnels
à préciser comment il fallait entendre
ça mais à la lecture à la re lecture de
cette réserve d'interprétation
je lui fais confiance que vous l'avez
sans doute fait à aucun moment ce
pouvoir n'est donnée a priori à la
conférence des présidents
ce pouvoir il appartient au président de
séance que vous êtes évidemment par
excellence monsieur le président de
l'assemblée nationale mais il ne peut
intervenir que lorsque des expressions
orales de défense des amendements sont
jugés répétitif abusive ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas à ce stade du
débat
parce que ce débat il a une grande
particularité c'est qu'on a un
gouvernement qui nous propose qu'ils
nous proposent un texte sur lequel on ne
sait rien du financement qui est
incapable de répondre à des questions
qui lui sont posées de manière très
précis sur l'assiette des cotisations
combien va coûter le fait que l'on fasse
sortir trois cent mille personnes du
système universel les syndicats nous
disent qu'ils ont un chiffrage à 65
milliards d'euros c'est quand même pas
rien mais le ministre ne nous en dit
rien le conseil d'état vous a pourtant
largement alerter sur le rock mélodique
madame monsieur marleix
si pardon si si le ce dirigé le
troisième de votre héros sur le même
sujet tout ça pour dire monsieur presque
que la défense de ces amendements elle
n'est pas du tout superflu
elle n'est pas là pour faire de
l'obstruction est là pour essayer
d'avoir des réponses et donc votre
interprétation du règlement ne donne pas
ce pouvoir à la conférence des
présidents a priori il faudrait laisser
notre collègue s'exprimait avant le
voyage interdit
que le conférence des présidents
prennent la décision qu'elle a prise sur
bien sûr monsieur prise en main de son
président je viens de recevoir comme
vous l'avez dit quelques minutes il y à
quelques minutes une liste des
amendements de monsieur jumelles est
identique alors et ensuite il est
précisé remplaçants la référence au
système universel par la référence au
système inéquitable
c'est un changement de mot que mes
camarades communistes ont jugé opportun
de nous proposer
bon alors il ya une série d'amendements
je suppose qu'ils ont peut-être été
répétée raison pour laquelle vous me
parlez 2184 mais je voudrais en avoir
l'assurance parce que là il n'est
question que des amendements de monsieur
jumelles sur un mot et c'est seulement
ce dans ce groupe
moi j'ai déposé beaucoup d'amendements
au titre de mon goût donc est-ce que
1184 c'est cette liste la fois x ou bien
est-ce que je dois m'attendre à ce qu'à
un autre moment vous ayez remplaçant la
référence au système universel
un dernier mot président vous allez voir
toute ma bonne volonté et ma bénévoles
ans c'est continuez monsieur mélenchon
protesté alors jeunes gens apaisé vous
écoutez votre président qui vient de
nous appeler à vous apaiser je pense
qu'on perd du temps inutilement je sais
pas ce que ça vous a rapporté sur le
plan tactique mais pour l'instant c'est
zéro
j'arrive pas à comprendre vos
motivations j'arrive pas à comprendre
motivation parce qu'on pourra en
discuter
bien qu'on payait monsieur mélenchon
continuer on n'est pas dans une
conversation votre interview du
président oui ma faim alors à ce moment
là dit - karabagh dansions d'accord je
m'adresse à vous mais je l'aimé collecte
ce sens les joueurs étaient très
posément votre question je vous
répondrais si je le peux j'y viens donc
en fait c'est la liste exhaustive que
multiplie 17 villes comme ne sommes pas
du tout dans le cadre d'un débat
d'obstruction ce sont les mêmes qui ont
été déposés 17 fois résidence n'ont pas
pu être déposés 17 fois les communistes
sont 16 dans leur groupe
ces cas n'a pas pu être déposée dix sept
fois que tu sais si vous avez raison
alors oui bon c'est assez simple 74 que
multiplient c'est ça fait 1180
4 et alors il n'y aura donc plus jamais
au fil de la discussion
d'autres cas où je vous lève et trois
fois a donc vous regrettez votre
première interprète je voulais dit y en
a trois en région ce résident j'entends
bien mais vous admettez qu'on vous pose
la question parce que je vous ai répondu
j'ai la juriste il ya je vous ai répondu
donc c'est compris voilà donc c'est
compris monsieur val au jeu président
qui nous soit permis d'essayer de
comprendre ce que vous nous dites vous
avez annoncé un certain nombre
d'amendements qui tomberait
automatiquement y compris ceux qui n'ont
pas encore été discuté c'était là
l'objet de notre question c'est sur
l'ensemble des amendements
est-ce que ce que vous venez de nous
deux nous distribuer est ce qu'il n'ya
que le groupe démocrate et républicain
qui est concernée ou est ce qu'il y à
d'autres amendements d'autres groupes
qui d'ici la fin d'examen la séance se
retrouver sous la décision léonine qui
est la vôtre
peta blement monsieur vélo je crois
qu'ici tout le monde a compris ce que
j'ai dit vous avez le droit de faire
semblant
je vous dis je vous dis que là écoutez
moi
écoutez moi
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas particulier g
j'ai juste indiqué j'ai juste indiqué
que lorsqu'un amendement qui a fait
l'objet de dépose simultanée et massif
avec le même terme même épithètes qui ne
concerne que les intitulés qui fait
l'objet du même exposé sommaire
lorsqu'il aurait été refusée par notre
assemblée au fur et à mesure que
surgiront à nouveau au gré du texte ces
amendements seront considérés comme
avoir été peu comme tombée et j'ai et
j'ai précisé qu'en l'espèce la concerne
et 74 amendements déposés
seize fois soit jusqu'au bout du texte
en tout et pour tout 1184 à maman voilà
alors si ça maintenant vous l'avez pas
compris moi je ne sais plus quoi faire
ces jumelles
de quoi s'agit-il jugement ayant été
ayant et ayant été extrêmement extrait
expressément citée par mois le fait
personnel est donc justifiée pas par moi
j'ai les ai il me permet et il me permet
de parler au nom du groupe nous avons
bien compris que votre objectif était de
déchirer le socle posée par ambroise
croizat à la libération pour la sécurité
des salariés et nous prenons donc votre
volonté d'ostraciser le groupe
communiste comme une légion d'honneur
vous avez désigné la sève de ceux qui
ont contribué à construire le système de
la sécurité sociale comme vos
adversaires privilégiée nous prenons ça
comme une légion d'honneur monsieur le
président monsieur le président vous
venez d'inventer le 49-3 du président de
l'assemblée nationale avant le 49-3
gouvernementale vous faites preuve
depuis le début de la séance d'un
autoritarisme qui n'a jamais eu lieu
dans cette instance d'actes unilatéraux
qui s'assoient sur la conférence des
présidents de droit constitutionnel
réinventer
réexpliquer d'une jurisprudence
extrapolé mais nous prenons ça comme une
légion d'honneur accordée aux
parlementaires communistes d'ailleurs il
nous a pas échappé que depuis le début
de la mandature toutes les lois qui ont
reçu la contribution des parlementaires
communistes statut la sncf le statut de
la sécurité sociale le statut de la
fonction publique mobiliser beaucoup
l'énergie des libéraux que vous êtes
et bien vous allez nous trouver sur
votre route à chaque fois que vous allez
blingué est ce qui fait l'état qui
protège l'état qui prend soin et on va
vous emmerdez sur le fond comme sur la
forme sur tous ces sujets là merci
monsieur le président de gens te
rappelles règlement
merci monsieur le président rappel au
règlement haute est de l'attique 58 sur
le fondement de l'article sans nous
avions décidé de ne pas rentrer dans ce
débat mais je pense que maintenant nous
sommes arrivés à un stade où ça n'est
plus simplement la question d'un débat
démocratique qui est en cause mais celui
de la défense de notre institution
nous savons parfaitement qu'il n'ya pas
ici un seul député qui valent plus qu'un
autre ni plus ni moins nous sommes tous
élus et à ce titre nous portons tous
ensemble la responsabilité de
l'institution dont nous faisons partie
mais manifestement nous ne la défendons
pas ni avec les mêmes armes ni avec les
mêmes objectifs
notre objectif à nous il est très clair
nous voulons ce débat sur le nouveau
régime de retraite et nous voulons un
verre un débat profond claire argumenté
propositions contre proposition et que
les français qui nous regardent au qui
nous écoutent puisse juger nous pouvions
avoir un doute sur le fait que cette
volonté pouvait être partagée depuis
hier nous n'avons plus de doute vous ne
voulez pas ce débat il vous fait peur
parce que précisément vous savez
parfaitement que nous avons les moyens
de démontrer vos arguments mais là mais
là où les choses ne vont plus c'est que
la question n'est plus celui du débat
sur les retraites la question c'est
celui du débat et de la défense de notre
institution
quand je vous entends remettre en cause
l'autorité du président de l'assemblée
nationale
quand j'entends un vice-président qui
conteste une règle qu'il sera chargé
d'appliquer lorsqu il présidera la
séance
quand je vous entends mettre en cause le
fait
autoritaire corps ne vous entend mettre
en cause le fait majoritaire qui fait
que en effet le groupe majoritaire a
voix prépondérante
pendant la conférence des merci monsieur
le président que vous en tant qu'enjeu
plus envie d'en utiliser des termes est
merci monsieur le président je vous dis
attention même si la séance suspendue
pour cinq minutes